and we're live all right Paul first of
all welcome thank you for coming here
and you are probably one of the most
requested people from the internet that
I've ever had so I feel good about that
and I'm honored he the first guy ever to
wear a mushroom hat okay that's really a
hat made out of mushrooms yeah it's made
from this Amadou mushroom
it's called foam nice momentary oh so it
was on birch trees throughout the world
but this is an example of why I think
shamanistic aliy plants mushrooms become
significant there's a plurality of
benefits
so this mushrooms a fire starter
mushroom it allowed for the portability
of fire there's no doubt that we came
from Africa we migrated north we
discover something new called winter
oops this allowed for the portability of
fire you can hollow this mushroom out
put embers of a fire inside and carry
fire for days if your clan could not
rekindle fire in Europe in the
wintertime you would die so when you
this has actually made by some ladies in
Transylvania yeah and it's a hardwood
conk oh well but when you soak it in lye
water you know ashes and water it
delaminates into this fabric whoa let me
feel that it's very soft it's also
called German felt
it's extremely flammable so
revolutionize warfare because during the
Napoleonic Napoleonic times this is the
the Punk that ignited gunpowder
even the Chinese invented you know the
Chinese invented gunpowder the Europeans
and that had the rifle so this loud
Flint's bark guns to ignite the
gunpowder this feels amazing it is as
high get a piece can you get that's a
great question depending on the size of
the conch on beats trees are much bigger
than birch these trees just naturally
get larger so the larger the conch the
more fabric you can tear but this
mushroom is made of mycelium and
basically that fabric is a cellular
fabric called mycelium
and this is I have actually I have one
that caught on fire because I'm gonna be
smoking a joint near me and the and the
embers of the joint got on my hat they
just immediately go up no it burns
really slowly so it's a fuse it's a
fantastic for delayed explosions it's
because you can light this thing and
beekeepers for hundreds of years use
this for smoking the hives of bees
because it's it's just we could we could
light it now I mean the whole thing with
one flick of the BIC and this thing will
smoke entirely in about 10 minutes and
turn nothing to nothing into white ash
Wow your fire alarms may go off though
yeah and so with this thing this larger
piece they would hollow this out put an
ember in there what they have they'll
have to blow on the Ember as they hello
well you could blow on a little bit and
you cap it and then you can put it in
your pocket the famous Iceman that was
found in the border of EA and Austria he
had this tethered to his right side
which is a position of significance you
know things that you need like your
knife you know and things that you want
to make sure you have right handed you
this on the right side so there's a this
one example is we have a threat of
knowledge of use of mushrooms that goes
over millennia and most of those threads
have been frayed or broken and in the
chain of knowledge but this is one of
the threads that was not broken and it's
significant I think it's we were much
more dependent upon mushrooms and when
we were forced people than we are now
seemingly in the cities but this coming
full circle very quickly
well mushrooms are weird in that some of
them are incredibly edible and
nutritious and other ones
I'll kill you and sometimes they look
really similar to each other well this
is with the mystery of mushrooms and I
think it speaks to also Michael phobia
the fear of mushrooms done mmm our
Gordon Watson first coined that term but
but we think about it in your visual
landscape with animals you see them for
months years and plants so you have a
very already factored but mushrooms that
come up and disappear in four or five
days some of them can feed you some can
kill you some can heal you some can send
you on a spiritual journey so to have
something so powerful and yet so
ephemeral it's natural for humans to
avoid that which they don't understand
out of fear because they don't know the
difference well you know 23 primates
consume mushrooms humans being one of
them and so that speaks for a long and
sexual use of mushrooms going back you
know and our primate of evolutionary
tree for a very very long time what how
many species of mushrooms are there you
know that you asked me that question
five years ago I would have said 1.5
million and now we're up to about five
million just being is being estimated
well plant fungi outnumber plants five
to ten to one and I just you know I you
know I speak at Ted and I've gone to
these TED conferences but it's shocking
with the smartest brains in the world
not until just recently did they realize
what us mycologists have known for a
long time thirty percent of the soil
mass when you're walking on soil the
thirty percent of the biological carbon
is fungal and the biggest because whoa
whoa whoa say that again thirty percent
thirty percent of soil is fungal mass
living in dead of healthy soil so and
this is the biggest repository of carbon
in the world in the ground is related to
these fungal networks so there is about
8.3 to about 10 million species on the
planet about right now about half of
those or fungal species the outnumber
plants up to eight to one ten to one by
by some estimates really nice
interesting metric and one meter of a
tree root
for every meter of a tree root there's a
kilometer of mycelium now think of that
three feet versus 2200 feet so that that
the extensiveness of the mycelial
network in our landscapes is vast and
it's a you is I called Earth's natural
Internet this is a these are membranes
that are literally sensitive I think
they're sentient they respond to every
footprint that we take on this planet
and as you walk across landscapes you're
breaking wood and that makes new
nutrition available so the composition
of fungi to find that new new nutrition
is fierce and so first to the menu wins
so this is something that we are now
understanding how essential they are for
preserving biodiversity and for the
health of the ecosystems as well as our
own personal health so when you say you
think they're sentient to what degree I
mean and you're not talking about just
like psilocybin yes we're kind of
intellectually provincial and that we
are using language invented terms and
order to describe concepts that we're
trying to we're struggling with so the
let me describe it this way that we
separated from fungi 650 million years
ago maybe you did dude I know some
people that are probably still well
basically we we are descendants of fungi
yeah
we share more common interests with
fungi than we do with any other kingdom
and fungi are closer to animals and the
art of plants animals came from funshine
you and I are actually fungal bodies I'm
speaking to basically another fungal
body right now so Joe Rogan I mean
whether you know it or not you you're
basically a fungal mass and from a
cellular point of view under the
microscope a human cells animal cells
and fungal cells are very very similar
we exhale carbon dioxide we inhale
oxygen as do fungus as the fungus does
we separated from fungi basically we
chose about to encapsulate our nutrients
in a cellular soccer stomach digesting
our nutrients within the fungal systems
digest their nutrients externally they
exhale oxygen
inhale carbon dioxide and their network
like design allows them to respond to
catastrophe and what I mean by that is
that the my silicone networks they're so
dense in the soil and they have
literally hundreds of billions of tips
and as these tips are growing out they
tend to be poly nuclei at the tips and
it allows them to upregulate new enzymes
acid sequences etc so if there's a new
ecological challenge a new food source a
new toxin or something the these fungal
networks are so a great plasticity and
being able to code for new sequences
from their DNA so all you need is one of
those hundreds of billions of tips to
find a new enzyme to break down a toxin
or a new food source and what happens
then is that information then is
incorporated genetically into the my
silikal network and the micelle immense
surges because it has new food logically
and so when it surges name creates a new
was called a sector of mycelium we now
know there's evidence that that my
silikal network then that it benefits
from that tip exploration and discovery
so these are like massively resilient
adaptive organisms that have a network
based design not dissimilar from that of
our neural networks not dissimilar from
the computer internet and more and more
that I explore this the more I'm
convinced that we will find network
based organisms throughout the cosmos
problem probably fungal systems and
fungal systems ultimately give rise in
our case animals it's more likely we'll
find fungal animal relationships all all
throughout the universe do you think
that there's some unknown way that
animals are connected in some sort of a
similar way as well that if if animals
came from fungus and fungus has this
incredible way of communicating with
each other do you think that there's
something like that within the animal
kingdom that we haven't discovered well
that stimulates my thought into and
talking about the microbiome the
mycelium landscapes networks they don't
live by themselves they select a
microbiome of bacteria and other
organisms that rest upon the mantle
these fungal networks are the foundation
of the food web well similarly we have a
microbiome and it's really interesting
that the the many of the bacterial
diseases that in fact fungi also affect
us our best antibiotics against bacteria
come from fungi penicillin being the
obvious example but we have found now
doing such next-gen sequencing and this
has never been published before that the
mycelial mats growing in the very same
wood chips in our case that had been
fermented we had a thousand full
difference in the relative abundance of
genre of bacteria from the very same
wood chips to different mushroom species
planted on those wood chips and the
micro biomes of that were created and
selected for by the mycelium were vastly
different this really strongly supports
the concept is the hypothesis was
quickly becoming a theory I was
committing the difference in a minute
but this really supports the concept
that I've long believed in a spouse that
these mice in little networks are not
just happenstance
they are just you're creating the
habitats in the flora and then
ultimately the fauna that are resident
within the ecosystem to guarantee the
plurality in the biodiversity of the
ecosystem by creating the plants that
crea that grow up that feed the animals
the insects to create the debris fields
and that feed the mycelium for the
benefit of progeny of the mushrooms out
form thereafter so these are
deterministic organisms that are setting
the stage for ecological evolution and
you think that they're doing this in a
conscious manner well see again we're
victim of our consciousness trying to
define what is conscious and what is
smart and one of the best arguments I've
had my brother bill is a super genius is
far smarter than myself
and he was editing one of my books my
celly I'm running how mushrooms can help
save the world and and he goes Paul you
cannot say that mycelium is intelligent
and you can't say nature is intelligent
I go wait bill I respect you but you
didn't realize that hypocrisy of the
statement that you're giving me you're
telling me nature is not in
and yet you are born of nature using the
mind to conceive the concept that
challenge the idea that nature is not
intelligent when you are part of nature
I rest my case
yeah that's that's in defense so yeah so
we're you know we create language and
words to describe concepts so you feel
like your brother was sort of hampered
by these predetermined categories that
we like to put things into it though you
have a word use that word the word is
very clearly defined in our ID thank you
thank you yes you know we Lent languages
code hmm and we don't have we haven't
elaborated the code yet to elucidate the
concepts that we're trying to articulate
that does not mean just because you
can't prove it's true doesn't mean it
hasn't happened right so as our
vocabulary increases you know as our
lexicon of language increases it got
more robust then I think we can better
better describe tests and and prove that
these concepts are true but we you know
we're biologically provincial when we
think about how limited we are we're
truly new Neanderthals with nuclear
weapons I mean this is when you look at
the how how important natural ecosystems
are try to replicate them they're very
very difficult to replicate due to their
complexity so I think the more that we
study nature most all of us scientists
that subscribe to the adage that the
more we study this subject the more we
realized we didn't know and the hubris
of us thinking that these things cannot
occur did not occur will not occur it
really speaks to our provincial attitude
towards nature the idea that these
fungus fungi are creating their
environment and and almost they're the
architects of this environment they're
they're establishing the landscape for
all these different creatures and and
life-forms to live is unbelievably
fascinating that the idea that the and
also that they're connected right
they're connected in some sort of almost
like a neural network and there's um
what is that thing in the Pacific
Northwest the one fungus group that's it
essentially the largest living organism
on the face of the earth
yeah the largest organism in the world
so far discovered is a mycelial mat 2200
acres in size and that's equivalent to
about 665 football fields and that's one
animal is one my
a little man one my Suleiman is a honey
mushroom that kills trees it's an edible
mushroom but think of this
I mean think so for those listeners out
there if any soil biologist know this
well if you go out and get some nice
rich soil a gram of it and you analyze
it the typically is a million five
million
microbes per gram in that soil then the
mycelium is growing out we have five or
six skin layers that protect us from the
infection the mycelium only has one cell
wall on the other side cell wall or
hundreds of millions of microbes for
ground that are trying to consume it
many of which the mycelium is able to up
regulate and constant biomolecular
communication with this ecosystem be
able to prevent predators from consuming
it thus allowing it to achieve the
largest mass of any organism in the
world this is amazing to me because it
means that is constantly in in
communication with the ecosystem being
challenged accepting alliances so guilds
of micro biomes are being created
selected by the mycelium and these
guilds in communities that cooperate in
order to prevent pathogens parasites
even competing guilds from coming into
the landscape so the dominance of these
fungi are to ensure the ecosystems that
give lives their progeny the rule of
natural selection of life is
reproduction so everything steers
towards reproduction so from an
evolutionary biology point of view what
will that organism do to help survive so
it can reproduce and and reproduction
through creating guilds of communities
the microbiome using the mycelium
network as the structural foundation of
the food web seems to be the name of the
game here
so this honey mushroom is what its camp
and that lives in the Pacific Northwest
how is it killing these trees it's a
root parasite so it comes in and kills
the trees and I spend a lot of time in
the old-growth forests and a lot of
hiking I've always been one wondering
about meadows in the subalpine regions
there's all these subalpine forests and
then you come out and is giant meadows I
suspect that the this honey mushroom is
a meadow maker it climaxes these trees
it kills them
they then die and then they grow
physically but then it clears the canopy
for the grasses but it was a prophetic
music is growing on dead material so
first is a pair of media mushrooms -
mushrooms first as a parasite kills the
tree then I say saprophyte or sap probe
that's another word for it it's a
decomposer it it breaks down that
material but as it decomposes the wood
30% of wood becomes water so the
mycelium generates water as the water
lenses are being created the Goethe now
you have more sunlight grasses and
flourish and so I've suspected that
these mushrooms are actually meadow
makers allowing then the elk and the
deer and marmots and whatnot to exist in
those Crossland environments it's a way
of rebuilding the nitrogen a source in
the soil so I think these are over great
and huge the timescales we have to get
away from the concept of our lifespan or
even 100 200 years we need to think in
millennial terms you know over many many
millennia this is unbelievably
fascinating the idea that they're
they're sort of the architects of their
ecosystem there are the architects of
our existence this is something that
there's some really fantastic research
that's come out in the past two years
I'm I'm a science ambassador for the
Triple A estimates from the vastness
science so I am a little bit out there
but I'm really happy that I have so much
scientific support these days because a
lot of things I've been talking about
for 20 years are now about well rooted
and been proven one of the things that
that has been so fascinating to me and
I'm still wrapping my mind around this
but you know the universe has created
about 13.8 billion years ago from the
Big Bang the earth coalesce autostart us
about 4.5 billion there are the earliest
records of life we have is about 3.8
billion years ago single-celled
single-celled organisms but just
recently and Lava Beds in south africa
they found my psyllium infused to the
lava 2.4 billion years ago now we split
from fungi 650 million years ago and
then in Brazil
last year they found a fully intact
apparently a fossilized mushroom
published in nature which is a very
reputable scientific journal and that
one is 1.4 billion years old so the
oldest multicellular organism in the
fossil record today is this fungus and
lava in South Africa 2.4 billion years
ago a fully formed mushroom who had as
its form
grew was growing 1.4 billion years ago
we were we separated from Funday 650
million years ago mushrooms have had
their form longer than we've had our
form by more than a billion years here
Jamie just pulled it up on the screen
here so we could take a look at the one
from Brazil so this is the pause as
though the image that you're familiar
with yeah this is the the one as that
that has just been published in the past
they have a great name as a tongue
twister to pronounce Gondwana a garis I
DS Magnificence why do they do that do
they do that to make people like me feel
stupid
they don't have to students want to
publish papers instead they can invent
names so it looks better if you have a
long Latin sounding name so but think of
that mushrooms had their form before we
had ours yeah these are elders these
these are ancient organisms these are
the really the overlord under Lords of
our ecosystem and I suspect and as these
neural networks they have more neural
connections into my Sileo master over a
thousand acres and we have in our brain
they are actually accumulating knowledge
genetic intelligence but I think that as
time goes on I hope that we will to
interface with them because I think that
there is a there is many benefits of us
communicating with mycelium that can
give us rapid responses to catastrophic
that's how they've evolved and we're now
the biggest walking catastrophe that I
know I'm walking across the planet and
we need to engage these fungal allies
for the benefits that we need to put
into plate in order to prevent the loss
of biodiversity it seems like a
communication gap would be very hard to
bridge the communication gap I mean if
we really did find a way to communicate
in some form with
mushrooms like the concept of language
like you were talking about just the
idea of nature and intelligence and
these words that we have that we have
these sort of concrete definitions in
our head that don't really apply to some
things that are very very confusing to
us like the idea of fungal intelligence
the idea that you could somehow or
another understand the language that
these things we wouldn't we don't even
understand dolphin language right well
what a classic example Japanese are so
clever at this they there's a slime mold
you know called Phi cerium poly
supplement and they had a and this slime
mold is very very good at navigating
through mazes and challenges I mean
first of food wins the conservation of
energy you know is rewarded so I set
this up they did several experiments the
fun most fun one is they they designed a
nutrient basic a nutrient like maze
replicating Tokyo and the Japanese
subway system and so they started with
Tokyo and they put oats which is a
nutritional source they inoculated what
is on this basic and Agra map with all
the major cities the nodes around Tokyo
and they then makes each of those nodes
had a piece of oat on them was a source
of nutrition the main boat was where
Tokyo was they inoculated it and then
they let the slime mold then grow and
first I grew out randomly exploratory
really you know just like you would do
do if you're a hunter or something
you're hunting on the landscape looking
for things and then after about twenty
eight hours it reorganized itself in the
most efficient way possible and
reorganize the Japanese subway system in
a more efficient manner than it's
designed today thus they said not me not
Paul Stamets this is a demonstration of
cellular intelligence Wow so this is the
tip of the proverbial mycelial iceberg
you know this is as
broad implications and I just want
people to suspend their disbelief and
this goes into it actually the evolution
of human consciousness and Terence
Mckenna was a good friend of mine
I love Terrence I especially love them
the last five years of his life because
he made fun of himself so much Terrence
people who took Terence way too
seriously in many levels but as his
brother Dennis which I think has been on
your show a couple times this is a great
ally great scientists but you know
Dennis said even if 10% of what Terence
said was true
it's freaking amazing and Terence and
Dennis both came up with a stained
stoned
a theory now it's not a theory it's a
hypothesis a hypothesis is speculative
but cannot necessarily be as not yet
proven a theory is a hypothesis that has
been tested and proven with facts so I
disagree with them and saying it's not
theories on hypothesis but the
hypothesis is the stone a part of the
stone Dave which I think you've alluded
to before is that with climate change
and as a savannas increase in our
primate ancestors came out of that are
the forest canopies there they're
tracking across the savanna and if
you're a hunter what do you look you
look for footsteps you look for Scott
and the most significant fleshy mushroom
bang out of poop and in Africa
hippopotamus elephants you know deer
antelope etc is sloppy cubensis it's a
very large mushroom you're hungry you're
with your clan you consume it and then
20 minutes later you're you are
catapulted in this extraordinary
experience psilocybin substitutes of
serotonin
becomes a better trip neurotransmitter
activates neurogenesis
it causes new neurons to form new
pathways of knowledge so that's a stone
date hypothesis and it speaks to a
mystery that the human brain basically
the brain cavity doubled in size in
about two million years some people say
is less is to less than 200,000 Homo
sapiens around 200,000 years Homo
sapiens arrived at 200,000 300,000 years
ago that's a big gap right
is it big guy well the science is like
that
you want you know to be scientifically
accurate here I need to show the the
extreme margins of what's been estimated
so if we accept two million years that
the innocents shown in the fossil record
this is true the oldest Homo sapiens
fossils are three hundred thousand years
old now but we have a subtle suddenly
doubling of the human brain and with
that our language centers increased our
ability to prognosticate to plan and
there's no explanation for this
currently and even though we may not be
able to prove it I asked people to
suspend their disbelief for a second now
think of this our primate ancestors are
going across the savanna they ingest
these mushrooms as a clan massive input
for anyone's eating these mushrooms huge
amounts of data is coming in fractal
patterns geometrical you know landscapes
occur you have empathy you have greater
courage you're fighting a sable sable
saber-toothed tiger you know one day
you're you have a fear of it we know now
from neurogenesis and the extinction of
the fear response that has been
clinically proven psilocybin allows you
to re set and have different
neurological pathways to respond to fear
overcoming the fear conditioned response
potentially PTSD and there's a lot of
research on this currently so but this
wouldn't happen one time with one
hominid group what happened two times
ten times having millions and millions
and millions and millions of times over
millions and millions of years this
leads to what I think is called this
should be called epigenetic neurogenesis
we know that there's a regeneration of
neurons we know this all Saabs
substitutes to serotonin it opens the
floodgates of the senses you have a lot
more data coming in and we know that it
has the extinction of the fear response
so if you're the leader of your clan
you've had this traumatic event either a
war or Cataclysm from earthquakes
whatever the case may be or encounter
saber-toothed tiger whatever if you're
the leader of that clan and you can
overcome your fear response you have
courage and you have empathy
those are leadership skills I think
people didn't take note of it
people like to fall leaders who are
courageous and yet kind who they can
trust
they'll have their best interests in
mind so I think this propelled I think
it's a lot it's a very good explanation
it's an unprovable hypothesis but now
we're at a junction and for the net and
we're ready for the next quantum leap in
human consciousness
I think psilocybin should be looked upon
as a nootropic vitamin and there's a
huge amount of interest in this Johns
Hopkins University's you probably well
know New York University UCLA elsewhere
in Europe there's major clinical studies
that have been conducted in the past two
years showing exactly what I'm saying
about overcoming fear response
neurogenesis overcoming PTSD this is now
medically quite seriously considered and
something that I think that we should
explore under controlled settings I'm
not into partying with psilocybin
mushrooms damn you know so good I can
understand
are you sure here's gonna be here in an
hour and a half and he's the creator of
shroom fest he's gonna be very upset
with your idea that you shouldn't party
with it
well I think there's greater benefit to
myself and and humanity I think these
are serious tools California has it you
know I'm sure you're probably aware
there it's up for legalization yeah I
was really quite surprised by that ya
know my work in did put some caveats
here all my work is covered by a Drug
Enforcement Administration license I've
published now four new species in the
genus philosophy including the most
potent psilocybin mushroom in the world
called Selassie our essence and to be
clear folks
nature provides I don't so Linda I have
my DEA license I mean everyone I suspect
there was a DEA agent who came to me and
wanted to get some salts Ivan probably
got set up a bunch time numerous times
appointment at all it was it was for it
the point was pretty funny you know I
had this one person who offered me just
huge amounts of money and I played with
him and I said no it's not enough and he
offered me more and more money presented
two hundred three hundred thousand
dollars and
and he was writing all these coded
letters and they really it was obviously
a DEA agent trying to set me up and and
finally got really frustrated because I
was playing with a guy I said I'm tired
of being set up like this I'm just gonna
play this sucker you know and so it
finally came to a point and you got
really really frustrated you get mad at
me because well how much money I go
there's not enough money on this planet
for me to ever give you a solo Simon
mushrooms so give it up so but but if
you say that's not enough money could
that be taken in as a negotiation well
not enough money on the planet I smell
some alien gotta come not enough money
on the planet yeah
afford not enough money it was not
enough money right before that goes tell
you know what see think that like if you
had like a really you know loosely
interpreting judge you come I suppose up
I never committed a criminal act so I am
but it's isn't it sort of like
conspiracy - I'm not a lawyer I wouldn't
have I mean you have to keep things in
context yeah I wouldn't play yeah
maybe you're more of a courageous person
when it comes to that stuff than me well
at some point I just got frankly pissed
off I'm sure enough playing with me
waste of your time gonna play with you
universe the table so but in any event
this is serious research yes and that's
um it's something that unfortunately
because it can't be marginalized by the
party atmosphere and yeah this is a
party drug there's a really amazing
study that just came out about five days
ago it's at Big Data study four hundred
and forty thousand people the prisoners
were surveyed over ten years and the
Department of Human and Health Services
data bank and they found an amazing
correlation if you had in this patient
in this prisoners one experience with
psilocybin in your life one experience
it reduced and that population compared
to the people who did not take assault
on mushrooms
an 18% reduction in burglary and and
larvae and larceny and up to a twenty
seven percent reduction and other crimes
including violent crimes
so that for Mama X I got my numbers
reversed is 27 percent reduction in
burglary 18 percent reduction in violent
crime now think of the damage not only
to the victims and the victims families
the court system the lawyers the
collateral damage people being upset
because they're being criminalized in
prison for something you know for merely
possession suicide mushrooms or
something like that but think of the
return on investment a four to six hour
experience creates a lifetime benefit to
society
reducing criminal activity by 18 to 27
percent this is phenomenal
mmm this is this is something that can
help the health of our of our human
psyche of our of our social system of
reducing trauma throughout in our entire
society it's time for us to wake up and
look at this as a much more
seasoned and intellectual fashion well
we have rational and not weighed down by
the ideas of mushrooms being a silly
thing yeah and so I I mean I have a few
pet peeves and I understand why people
want to use a bit but the word shroom
just drives me crazy shroom fest ran the
truth with all due respect I understand
but you know let's not be children about
this let's be adults you know you're a
serious person yeah I I'm also in a non
serious personal in many levels but I
know when it comes to something that is
so powerful that is so important let's
not jeopardize its use medically and
benefit society in the future by
appealing to the lowest common
denominator but let's be adults in the
room yes I agree with you to a certain
extent but I also think that it's got to
be incredibly frustrating for a guy like
you that has the kind of information
that you have bouncing around your head
in relationship to the way the rest of
the world views it see to a person like
myself who I don't know nearly as much
as you know but I know quite a bit more
than the average person when it comes to
psilocybin and mushrooms or and medium
Amanita muscaria or terence mckenna's
ideas the shroom fest doesn't bother me
but for a serious research for like
yourself it's got to be like ah you're a
part of the problem right well it's
making it silly it's a tip
the leery problem right right it held
back their bona fide research in this
subject for years there's a movement
right explain that please it is as a
movement right now to move Saul
sovereign from schedule one to schedule
two the schedule one means illegal drug
that has no medical benefits schedule
two means it's a drug that has medical
benefits so there's a serious movement
going on right now within the FDA to
have it be recategorize because in the
words of FDA researchers I know one
arms-length removed is that they've
never seen anything with such a strong
safety profile they gives so much
benefit at so little cost for such a
long time this is a drug and a category
of its own this is really important so
let's not jeopardize it it is really
important but you're never gonna stop
kids from calling it shrooms well you
know and I want to give a pass here I
want to get a pass and the coming of age
you know when I was 16 - you know the
age you know 20 to 24 it's the
coming-of-age ceremony now I'm going to
tell you something that's very deeply
personal and it's very significant in my
life I had a congenital stuttering habit
I could not speak I could not look at
Joe Rogan in the eye right now without
you know I had like the King's Speech
you've seen the movie exactly like that
but worse in my case I went through six
years of speech therapy I was
interviewed for special education I grew
up in a small town called Columbiana
Ohio and I could not speak now but the
type of stuttering habit that I have and
had I don't stutter to animals I had pet
snapping turtles and I would talk to him
all the time and I don't stutter when I
sing but I could not l acute without
stuttering constantly and please people
out there don't finish a stutterer
sentence the type of stutterer category
that i have been in is that we would try
to trick our brain with a prepositional
or adverbial phrase halfway through the
sentence that we're stuck on because
we're thinking three or four sentences
ahead and the only way you can do is
trick the brain so I had to come up with
a new neural
a pathway to trick my brain so I could
get out of my stuttering rhythm that was
just repetition I couldn't get out of
and then one day before I ever had
psilocybin mushrooms
I bought some a bag of them and I
thought I got I had no information I
just bought the bag for about 25 bucks
and I went out for a walk in the woods
in Ohio and there was a beautiful oak
tree that I used to climb the top of the
very top of the tallest hill you know hi
oh we don't have mountains we have Hills
and it was in the summertime and so I
thought sentence setting is important I
knew that so I went for a walk and I ate
the bag the whole bag I was walking how
many I was well it was about I know it
was about a half an ounce to an ounce so
I'm here yeah so we're talking this is
all this is this is the elevator ride
beyond the 10th floor
you know so 8 to 16 grams is probably on
the order about 20 grams you know so no
and but I didn't know no I had no wonder
so but I knew that I wanted I wanted my
destination with this tree right so I
walked and walked and I came at the tree
and I was eating the mushrooms and and
then I started feeling the effects and
so it was great because I was climbing
the tree and I was getting higher in the
tree and higher in my brain well that
seems like a terrible thing to do and I
climb to the top of the tree and this
beautiful landscape but it was there was
these summertime is a boiling black
clouds in the horizon I go oh that's
cool you know and so this big summer
storm was coming then the clouds were
dark and boiling and and they're coming
close and I could hear the Thunder and
you know and and then I'm gonna higher
and higher and the winds pick up and the
tree started moving and I started get a
vertical because I was like oh my god
I'm getting so freakin high on these
mushrooms and so I grabbed the tree and
held on the tree and it became my axis
mundi into the earth
and then the Lightning started coming
closer and then lightning strikes I got
really close and the light would hit and
I got I saw fractals for the first time
the the atmosphere became liquid I saw
there's liquid waves of this
multi-dimensional geometrical patterns
everywhere and the sparks of lightning
would just create this amazing crescendo
of secondary tertiary well you know
fractals all around me and I was oh my
there's amazing I said this is what I
read about you know and so the storm
came and lightning strikes are all
around me and I was it washed with rain
and I was up there and I feel I felt in
touch with Gaia the universe my heart
opened up I felt one with all I was like
oh my gosh this is such a powerful
spiritual experience I had no idea no
matter what anyone is read as you
probably know it cannot describe the
experience and then a dawned on me wait
a second Stamets you're in the tallest
tree on the tallest hill from miles in
the middle of a lightning storm this is
not the best place to be and so I
realized I could be killed up here
suddenly I had a reality rush like you
know you're you could turn into a god
imagine hi I'm 20 grams of mushrooms hug
at a tree the Lightning comes it hits
you maybe you were the Savior maybe need
to get back to that tree
maybe you're the chosen one so I thought
I was you know I it was an incredibly
spiritual and wonderful experience but I
also had the fear and this comes comes
with the hero's journey you know you
always have the the dark side you always
have not just the light side but as
counterbalance with the dark side and I
realized I'm like gosh I'm gonna I could
die up here and that's a well I don't
dice NamUs which where are your issues
this this get something out of this
experience and I said this stuttering
hab is ridiculous and I'm not stupid and
I saw I said to myself stop stuttering
now stop stuttering now I said that
dozens hundreds of times over and over
and over and fortunately the storms went
past and held onto the tree and soaking
wet I came out of the tree and walked
back to where I was living and then the
next day I got up I didn't see anybody
and I was walking on on this path and a
sidewalk and there's a lady that I
really liked a lot and but she was
always attracted the super self-assured
jocks and things like that she was
actually very kind and sweet but I
didn't want to stare at her in their
eyes because I would stutter and it's
humiliating for us so the more
humiliating us stutterers feel the more
we stutter and so it's a really slippery
slope and so I would avoid eye contact
and so for the first time she walked
towards me she's a good morning Paul how
are you she was always so nice to me and
I was terrified because I would
embarrass myself and I looked at her
straight in the eyes and I said I'm
doing fine how are you and I stopped
stuttering and one day and this speaks
to now what was been medically proven is
that we can reset the neurology of the
human brain through neurogenesis
I believe that experience allowed me to
map new neurological pathways that
allows me to l acute in a way that I
could not l acute before now just to be
truthful here if I drink a lot of
alcohol I'm in a loud bar because that's
stutterers and your martial artists I've
been a martial artist all my life and we
have peripheral consciousness so if
someone comes to a door you know into
the bar and I'm looking at you I know
that they've come through so this hyper
alertness that s martial artists have
you know of knowing things in the
circumference around us in the
peripheral environment is distracting so
if I drink a lot and there's a loud a
lot of noise and a lot of people coming
in our doors I'm hypersensitive to
intruders
and then that's what I'll start
stuttering if a person's talking to me
asking me how do you go to mushrooms
it's like filling a well with a teaspoon
because I'm worried about the guy who
just came through the door room there
who looks like he may not be a safe
person to be in this environment right
now so that's there's a time that I'll
you only give 10% of my brain to
communicating to the person in front of
me my 90% of my brain is hyper aware in
the circumstantial environment around me
time for another trip to the tree to
cure that last 10%
but that's my personal story that's
amazing it's not an immortal one but it
worked for you that's what's important
work for me and I was at Crater Lake
Lodge and and the waiter came up to me
and he goes he's about 17 18 years of
age a busboy actually and my wife and I
my wife looked at me and I looked looked
at her and I said should I yeah go ahead
so I told her I told this busboy the
same story now this guy was totally
straight looked like he was a super
conservative from a conservative family
we told this whole story and his eyes
were wide open because when you meet
other stutterers and you talk to them
they're really desperate for a solution
so I never knew what happened to this
young busboy but I think I changed his
life forever I hope you did so I had a
good friend growing up and his brother
was severely stricken with it
to the point where he would have to
wince closed his eyes and look down you
know he would talk to you and he just
couldn't get over it it was but he won't
stutter to animals hmm they won't
stutter when he sings so what do you
think it is like what is what is
happening like do you well I think this
well there's several things it could be
trauma when you're a child combined with
neuropathy I was told by one
psychiatrist who was a specialist in
this at a conference that there is a
theory that in the seventh month in the
womb you or your neurons failed to make
all the connections that are needed to
so that makes sense to me because I
would reroute with preposition
prepositional or adverbial phrases to
try to jump around they're all habitual
loop try man but I think this speaks to
increasing intelligence and we all will
suffer from some form of dementia and
neuropathy occurs there is a really
wonderful safe and legal mushroom to use
that leads to neurogenesis and that's
called lion's mane and lion's mane is a
cascading white icicle edible and choice
mushroom they sell in the stores the
lets doors grocery stores grill over you
lion's mane they're called um various
brand names one night love is called
pompom Blanc
it looks like pom-poms some cheerleaders
and lion's mane contains a
we in unique group of compounds
beautiful called
Aaron a scenes and harissa nuns and
these regenerate myelin on the axons of
nerves and so this is a mushroom comedy
she discovered this in 1994 Japanese
researcher and he postulated as a
potential preventive or treatment for
Alzheimer's muscular dystrophy etc but
do you take it I take it every day every
day have you take it in raw form or dig
it in capsules so you buy it yeah we
have a we have an extensive product line
you do yes how do you get to that host
defense com host defense calm why host
defense that's part of your innate
immunity response supporting your
immunity but we are main businesses at
fungi calm and I registered that many
myself I'm kind of proud of that it cost
me 25 bucks 1994 wow yeah so winterize
yourself but lion's mane is a safe
mushroom to consume there are several
clinical studies out on treating mild
cognitive dysfunction but there's two
mouse studies that I think are quite
illustrative and this is translational
medicine this translates from mice
experiments to humans we already know is
that it has aspects of neurogenesis when
you go into Alzheimer estate of
Alzheimer's which is a big complex but
one of the characteristics is the
formation of amyloid plaques
demyelination of the neurons myelin
transmits the neural signals
demyelination occurs there's outer
sheath on the neurons is interrupted by
amyloid plaques that then prevent
neurotransmission so the experiments of
the mice which i think are so
interesting was one experiment was the
the maize experiment where the mice were
put into an arena and they went out a
corridor and they they went one way in
the corridor they'd find food the other
way is no food well very quickly the
mice learned you know you go out the
corridor go to the left you'll find food
they injected it then without toxic
polypeptide that induces amyloid
plaque formation that is a neurotoxin
very quickly after two weeks or so the
mice develop neuropathy they got
confused they couldn't remember which
way to go
it randomized upon giving these mice
again mushrooms for a few weeks they
nearly read normalized upon sacrificing
the mice in the first part of the
experiment they saw like my plaques and
then demyelination the second part of
the experiment of course another subset
of mice they found that the myelin
regrew and the amyloid plaque had
resolved this is post mortem you say bye
say so
well there's 100 miles you're basically
cutting off a representative sample
where you sacrifice them you determine
yeah that's representative the
population now the remaining population
is alive they fed them the mushrooms and
they found that they regained
neurological function Wow the other
experiment which I find is even more fun
is and this was known in Japan they put
on like 100 mice in an arena and they
put a toy in the middle of the cage now
the mice got excited they came up and
sniffed it and smelled it and they got
really excited and and they sat there
with with counters to measure there were
points of contact how many points of
contact that mice have exploring a new
toy it's like a really good baseline
hundreds of data points and they do the
same thing then they introduced this
cyclic peptide and this neurotoxin and
the mice then after a while we run
interested didn't have imagination no
curiosity they put in a new toy
they were disinterested they did the
same thing now even their full-blown
dementia-like symptoms gave them lion's
mane mushrooms and after a few weeks
when they put in a new toy they came
back to near normal levels upon
sacrificing the mice they found that day
my plot quite resolved and Milan had
regenerated and neurogenesis not
occurred this is a smart mushroom now
the tragedy that we face I believe as a
society is we have people like yourself
people like me we're all going to suffer
through neuropathy we have a lifetime of
a body intellect of knowledge that we're
going to start losing so what is a loss
to society of our elders forget
not remembering so I think this is
something that's really extraordinarily
exciting is not patentable this is the
drug companies have no interest in this
but this is probably the number one
thing that people can do in my mind to
pranati preserve cognitive function but
to expand it now I personally would love
to see it legal to stack them both
together
stacking psilocybin with lion's mane and
I think that stacking thing and then
combining it with vitamin d3 now by
suggest vitamin d3 niacin because those
of you who've had a niacin flush
you know 200 milligrams of niacin or
more you get red you get itchy and
neuropathy typically is presented at the
fingertips at the end of your toes and
your fingers and your peripheral nervous
system as you have neuropathy the nerve
endings begin to die backwards so my
idea here is because there are different
receptors being activated by psilocybin
then with the Arron a scenes from lion's
mane if you stacked lion's mane with
psilocybin mushrooms with niacin the
advantage is and is hypothetical but
this is something I think is well worth
testing is the niacin can help drive the
neurogenic benefits of salsa Ivan and
Aaron a scenes to the end of the
peripheral nervous system so we actually
have planning right now a clinical study
in Oregon with lion's mane mushrooms the
physicians who've looked at the research
which is robust are convinced and that
it adds worthy and they have their own
funding so we can do have any 30 study
is what we hope to do 30 patients and we
hope to begin that study in the next
year it was a phenomenal to see how that
would affect people with CTE people like
football players boxers people with a
cross damage yeah across the board yeah
I'm the benefits and this is something
that when you're depressed you're not
creative and you're such that your
immune system is depressed as well
you're psychologically emotionally
depressed and you're not as creative
when you are happy you are creative and
your immune system is better so this
could be fundamental to disease
mitigation
across the board so this is some of the
this is there are so many different
examples like this where mushrooms need
to be advanced to the front stage of
consideration by serious scientists and
give up your michael phobia or even your
what I call silo phobia the irrational
fear of psilocybin mushrooms and look
upon these with new eyes and you drop
your prejudices and just look at as a
serious scientific analysis Wow
how is this received like in the general
scientific community is there skepticism
or well I I love my skeptics because
unless they're prejudiced against you
and some people are you can never
convince them but if you know scientists
when they see the datasets and they see
there's a dozen or more publications
with scientists without commercial
interests who have done this
independently then it's being taken very
seriously so though the whole medical
community right now you know I speak at
a number of medical conferences TEDMED
American Academy of Dermatology have
been keynote speakers you know many
medical conferences and and it's great
because I can take people who are
totally skeptical and most of them walk
out of that room convinced and why
shouldn't we think that fungi are
sources of medicines I mean penicillin
may is tipped World War two in our favor
so where the job the Japanese and
Germans did not have penicillin even
though Alexander Fleming discovered in
1928 in 1941 a lab tech researcher went
to a market in Chicago found a moldy
cantaloupe and Alexander Fleming's
strain of penicillin was too weak it
couldn't be commercialized this this
lady researcher who found this moldy
cantaloupe found a Penicillium strain
there was 200 times more potent and as a
result of that in war the most of the
casualties were died from infections and
so the British and the English the
English and the
Americans had penicillin the Germans and
Japanese did not and so it is as a great
NPR analysis on this on the history of
penicillin and it is one of the major
factors in helping tilt the balance in
the favor of the Allied powers against
the Axis powers so concerned with the
researchers in England they impregnated
their clothes with spores of this mold
strain so if our laboratories were
bombed or they were captured if one of
them escaped they could regenerate the
culture from their clothing whoa Wow
this speaks to panspermia we're all
carrying micro biomes of fungi the fact
that you and I are here together means
that I have now inoculated you with my
microbiome of selected fungi so Joe you
are now a vector whoa awesome
congratulations now there's the the
frustrating aspects of what is the word
that you use fungi phobia that were used
in Biko phobia Michel phobia the
frustrating aspects are first of all
prohibition right the sweeping
psychedelic Act of 1970 that made
psilocybin mushrooms illegal right and
and then on top of it the commercial
pharmaceutical industry which doesn't
want to have anything to do with
anything that it can't patent and has so
many doctors and so many researchers in
its pocket so you have two issues there
right you have one issue that people
which is obviously why you don't like
the word shroom people think of
mushrooms as a party drug like being
silly
you know freaking out doing something
stupid regrettable actions and then
afterwards going wow we got so crazy
thinking of it as a frivolous sort of
thing that you would engage in whereas
what you're trying to do is show the the
absolute hard science do you feel that
this absolute hard science is I mean you
must feel but it's unfairly matando
it's Iseman but there's been a title
change in pharmacology of the use of the
psilocybin and in his utility as a
therapeutic agent is there's a title
change I think now there's a over 700
patients have gone through Johns Hopkins
clinical trials for things like
end-of-life depression PTSD their
studies out on treating alcoholics and
drug addicts so and this is important to
communicate to people and John Hopkins
study in particular dr. Roland Griffiths
a great great scientist he's been
running in championing these studies
came up with a very interesting series
of analyses some of the take-home points
were only 70% of the people described
this awesome experience therapeutically
under controlled settings at John
Hopkins with a very high dose assault
Simon as being beneficial only 70% 70%
30% was saying I didn't like that in a
retrospective study 14 months to two
years later the 70% of the people who
said it was a beneficial experience
still described it as one of the most
significant beneficial experiences of
their lifetime and interviewing their
friends their spouses they saw a
permanent residual effect from the
benefits of the experience there were
nicer people there's no nice thing along
or less prone to anger they had many of
values that we would cherish as an
improved community of individuals the
33% of the people who had a native
experience the negativity of the
experience did not extend beyond the
experience themselves so they didn't
have collateral damage where we had
collateral benefit so the positive
people saw it as a positive experience
and the memory of the experience this is
so cool the memory of the experience
kept them optimistic hopeful and they
felt benefits from just remembering the
experience the people had a negative
experience they just you know wouldn't
do that again
so these mushrooms are obviously they're
not for
every one but for the people who do
benefit they benefit substantially don't
you feel that a lot of the people that
have those negative experiences at least
from my understanding a lot of it are
people that have some serious issues
that they're not dealing with and ego
problems and the mushrooms expose that
and they try to wrestle the mushroom I
mean when absolutely that's I think they
very well put I think that's a big issue
some people are afraid of their inner
self they you know we're all you can't
paint the canvas black and white yeah
we're a big spectrum of complex you know
personality traits and what happened to
somebody when they're two years old five
years old what trauma they experienced
you know it's very complex to be able to
make these statements but I think as a
group there are some people who are on
the edge and they may not control their
innermost emotions and they're afraid of
that in normal state of consciousness so
they're afraid they're might lose their
control right yeah I mean I've had
personally some terrifying psychedelic
experiences but the way I've gotten
through them is just to give in just to
give in and for a person like myself is
kind of a control freak especially when
I was younger it's it's a hard thing to
do just because you like no no I'm gonna
be fine
no no I'll [ __ ] this you know I'm gonna
know that I don't like where this is
going I'm gonna stop this right now I'm
gonna put a halt to this i'ma bring
myself back to sobriety like it's
impossible it's not going to happen so
you have to figure out how to just let
go and how to just like really let go
and Trust the mushroom or the DMT or
whatever it is you're on to take you on
this ride and you'll be okay when it's
over and if you can't do that that's the
bad trip and I've seen a lot of people
have bad trips
what's the close friends we we are the
casualty of the fact that we don't have
an infrastructure tradition in our
societies like First Peoples and Native
Americans do they have set up a
structure they have a tradition shamanic
shamanic tradition rituals elders
they've done this for a long time I have
set in setting down they know how to
treat these powerful medicines in the
right context yes and we lack that you
know did you know that mushrooms were
specifically banned from beer in the
Varian beer act of 1516 whoa and
mushrooms and henbane and other plants
were used in Meads psychoactive beers
and and celebrated by people practicing
pagan religions in Europe in the forest
and the struggle between I believe
Christianity monotheism versus
polytheism and nature based religions
there was a collision course and then
under pressure of the church they banned
the addition of these plants that could
be your gateway to God because the
church wanted to be in between you and
God they wanted to get the Thai things
they wanted to meet your portal and
control access to the divine mm-hmm and
so these mushrooms were looked upon as
being specifically a threat to
monotheism and Christianity so the the
varium Burak banda mushrooms that's
incredible
terrence had some pretty interesting
ideas about that pterence McKenna did
one of the things that he said that he
believed that as the climate changed and
some mushrooms became less and less
available
they started preserving them and honey
because you can preserve things and
honey and that in preserving things and
honey you also run into the possibility
of fermented honey
and then fermented honey becoming Mead
you go into more of an alcohol culture
than a psychedelic culture which is
really like on the opposite end of the
spectrum alcohol culture is loosened
inhibitions wild behavior less thought
of the consequences of your actions
less introspective thinking much more
chaos right and that he believes that
this has probably resulted in some sort
of a shift or he believed rather before
he passed it was resulted in some sort
of a shift from these more communal
mushroom worshipping cultures to what
you saw like in you know the Inquisition
and some of the more chaotic times in
history I would respectfully disagree
with the second part of that analysis
not what you're saying but what Terence
would have been saying much and being
preserved in honey is a way of
preventing them from rotting right
nothing to do with Mead well you did I
think it did have something to do with
me right the amount of alcohol being
produced versus
dose that you would get mmm it seemed to
me this all Simon dose would be so much
more powerful than the small amount
alcohol you be right
am i misrepresenting what he was saying
no I don't think so I think you know
you're you have a you just disagree with
his initial yeah and that's okay you
know Terrence isn't you know Terrance's
it was a very smart guy and I still
appreciate I love him but wandering
thoughts and they were amazing
well his time wave zero was totally BS
well that was crazy
that was crazy yeah the the end of time
occurring on his birthday I go don't you
think his low egocentric well he also
had some strange sort of a computer
program and I tried to follow it many
many times some of the lectures that he
gave on that computer program that
represented time wave zero what the idea
was for people interested he just
thought there was going to come a point
of ultimate novelty and somehow another
conveniently he had that point
coinciding with both his birthday and
the end of the Mayan calendar right yeah
yeah his birthday was December 21st 2012
as well I think celebrate that's totally
but he basically got the math to conform
to the convenience of his birthday so
it's like whatever we're all guilty of
being human yeah I mean even the great
ones yeah I mean and he was a great but
he was one of my favorite people in
terms of like listening to his
recordings he ever listened to
psychedelics Ilan
oh yeah amazing podcast one of the best
articulate of the English language I've
ever heard yes yeah I agree and as is
his brother yeah every time is which
what brings you back to the stoned ape
theory one of the things that his
brother talked about and maybe you could
elaborate on this was the impact that
psilocybin has on the creation of
language and he thinks that the very
pathways that you were discussing that
psilocybin sort of empowers that that
may very well have been how human beings
started elaborating on language oh I
think he's correct on that because
glossolalia and we know that
neurogenesis occurs in the hippocampus
glossolalia is the ability to to speak
and l acute languages and new words as
languaging your ability to language is
in
you know under the experience that so
Simon speaking the neurogenesis and
exactly what we've been talking about is
that basically your hippocampus is your
Centre for learning and memory and this
is why the mice got better because
neurogenesis was occurring in the
hippocampus and so they regained their
memory and they were able to learn and
so yes I think this neurogenesis not
only occurs in the hippocampus but I
think it can also occur in the
peripheral nervous system I have an
extraordinarily powerful story that I
would like to tell about neurogenesis
and it was from a good friend of mine
named Bill Webb he lived in Big Sur
California he was a friend of Ansel
Adams and Henry Miller wrote a copic
Tropic of Capricorn whatever it was in
the 60s is a big part of the movement in
the 60s and 70s and Ansel Adams is the
very famous photographer and Bill Webb
was a mentor to me I met him arise on 20
years of age I was writing about my
first book philosophy mushroom
philosophy mushrooms and our allies you
wrote your first book at 20 action was
18 you bad [ __ ] yes it was a
weirdest I mean I haven't told anyone
this in 30 years but I went up to a
place called Montana books in Seattle
and I had my manuscript and I walked
into the bookstore because I was told
Montana books was a kind of an
avant-garde book publisher in that and
early 1970s and so I was told to go up
there and I made an appointment and I go
in I'm meeting with a publisher and he
goes listen this is an interesting
little field guide you wrote but this is
not our market you know you really need
a book representative you need an agent
and so the best agent I know by far is
Bill Webb you know but I haven't seen
bill Webb in two years but you know you
really need to see Bill Webb and when he
said those words the door opened a
little bell rang and in walked bill Webb
it was like the publisher goes this is
freaking crazy you know so bill Webb and
I became tightly bonded he was a father
figure to me he was in his 70s when I
met him so bill and I went down to Big
Sur
we trip together of the great mentoring
you know father-son relationship and
Bill and I became very tight and then
bill was about 82 years of age and he
calls me up and says Paul I have to tell
you something that's so important and I
want you to listen so you understand
Paul I go yeah bill hi how are you doing
he goes well I'm not doing too well I'm
losing my sight I'm losing my hearing
and getting a getting old sucks
I said but I want to tell you something
that's really important you know great
bill hasn't tell me - no Paul I want you
to absolutely swear to me you'll tell
this to other people I go got it bill
hang out okay bill you know you're late
I you know I made the promise what is it
he goes okay
I've had this freaking hearing aid and I
hate it I can't hear the birds or the
waves breaking on the beach and that's a
big part of the Big Sur experience about
the cliffs the big sur and I said well
how's this for late and he goes well I
did a five gram dose of cubensis that's
the hero's journey where people were
listening five grams as his is it you
know you're on the floor and he was on
this deck and it was house and and he
noticed that he didn't his hearing aid
he could hear the the birds and the
waves and things like that and he's
laying there just you know he's like 80
80 mid-eighties at that point and he's
just like I'm just incredibly blissful
experience he's coming there to
reconcile his own mortality the fact
he's going to die he's thinking about
his life and he's you know kind of
dreaming in that dreamscape then he
hears click click click click click
click click he looks around and he goes
what's that noise he shakes his ear and
maybe something is a yeren click click
click click click click click he looks
around and he said he's driving me crazy
I go where is the sound coming from and
he finally looked over and it was ants
walking on the deck by near his head he
could hear their footsteps neurogenesis
Jesus Christ and this is easily
measurable metric for my vasila
psilocybin experience while he is fully
on the
experience he said he uses hearing aid
for three or four days now I've
mentioned it just do mushrooms again and
keep the hearing you know well that's
basically he ran out of cubensis and so
he was asking me for cubensis night I'm
sorry I can't get provided to you so
I've mentioned this now to several the
clinical researchers who have DEA
license who are doing the clinical
research this is the easily measurable
metric you can as people are fully you
know in these sessions they could be
giving them auditory stimulation to see
if the auditory nerve is undergoing
region erosion ASIS and so this is
something that i think that can be
incorporated in the clinical studies to
see if this is true but bill was in
Phatak and when bill webb spoke he had
an enormous gravitas this guy was as
serious intellectual so i think this is
a n of one study you know one individual
but i think this is something that
medical researchers did you pay
attention to what do you think could
possibly regenerate anything that
quickly though like how could it happen
so quickly that during the excites for
our trip because there's like nodes of
crossing and is there's an
interconnectedness that occurs and
there's a great graphic which i didn't
send you in advance showing this your
brain without psilocybin this your brain
will with psilocybin and there's a
massive amount of neural connections
that are occurring so I think you know
the just like water chooses the path of
least resistance I think that
neurologically if if there is a
neurological pathway that can help you
as a species as an individual survive
should there be a saber-toothed tiger on
the horizon then I think that the
economy of energy and nature would
reward the neurological pathways they
were like most likely to lead to your
survival so I I think that neurogenesis
across the brain occurred just like me
with my stuttering we and it was another
neurological pathway but in bills case
when he lost his access to those
mushrooms then neuropathy you know
became more resident and prominent and
so what we're looking at these images
but Jamie's the best we just we're
looking at these images and could you
explain to us what these are well your
brain on magic motion ANSI Reagan's
mantra here yeah this is the push this
up to your faces okay the the placebos
on the left this is a your your normal
representation of interconnectedness
between the nodes of your brain so try
to explain this to people most of the
people are just listening rather than
okay so the the one on the left it
basically shows connections between
neuronal nodes that may be on the order
of 40 or 50 different notes of crossing
the one on the right was psilocybin is
literally in the hundreds and the nodes
of crossing not only are more of them
but the thickness of the lines speaks to
how robust those nodes of crossing are
for for carrying neurological signals so
this is pretty amazing now this also
influences I think is important for our
US military you know for for coders for
people who are trying to solve very
complex datasets the ability of you to
have increased cognition and increased
intelligence and this is why micro
dosing is the rage in Silicon Valley the
enormous number of coders are micro
dosing right now and for those who are
listening this loose use philosophy
cubensis as the standard species because
that's the one that's mostly grown and a
half a gram to a quarter gram you have
liftoff you know five grams is the
full-blown hero's journey a lot of
people will take between two and four
grams as a moderately spiritual
experience four grams being higher and
so micro dosing is is taking a dose so
low that if at most you might feel it a
little bit giddy the first time you take
it the first day but you build up a
tolerance immediately the second day
second third day you would feel nothing
so it's on the order of like a tenth of
a gram of cubensis where people are
taking this and then they're taking it
repeatedly over time and coders in
Silicon Valley from the biggest computer
companies that we all know this is a not
only a fashion but a tool that they're
seeing the increased ability for coming
up with codes and is a competitive
advantage in the capitalistic system I
have a good friend who's a world
champion kickboxer and one of the best
in the world
he micro doses daily and he's been doing
it over the last like I want to say
probably a year or so and he has
achieved phenomenal improvements in his
performance because of that he says that
when he's sparring it's almost like he's
psychic like he knows what people gonna
do before they do it
he said his mood is better he feels
better he just feels more balanced and
he'll take days off and when he takes
days off and even though he's completely
sober while he's micro dosing because
he's really only micro dosing there's
something about taking days off where
everything just feels like kind of
shitty just doesn't feel good and then
he's like oh I didn't I didn't take my
micro dose and so he takes it again and
goes right back to that place but he
feels like he's in the matrix well
actually he is probably good that he
interrupts it because it washes those
receptors clean of this whole siphon and
my second time do you think you should
interrupt for two days out of out of
seven so five days on two days off now
I'm not making official recommendations
I'm just saying I will from from my my
small amount of knowledge on the subject
I I think that makes sense that's
consistent with traditional Chinese
medicine it's also consistent for those
of us who drink coffee like myself you
drink coffee for five days you take two
days off that next day is a strongest
cup of coffee you've had in a long time
you know because me and my friends who
are just coming to the next podcast
after this we just got done doing sober
October so no alcohol no marijuana
no nothing well we drank coffee but
that's it and when I stopped smoking
marijuana the first thing that happened
is my dreams became rocket charge
like very bizarre like crazy lucid
strange weird dreams not lucid in the
sense that controlled them but lucid in
the sense that I realized I was dreaming
and I was just like having incredibly
vivid vibrant dreams and I would wake up
from them and be certain that what I had
done was real like I'd one dream and I
fell asleep on the couch and while I did
fall asleep on the couch but while I was
asleep I was like oh I'm struggling to
get this blanket over me while I'm on
the couch and I'm pulling it but it's
stuck under the cushions I'm struggling
and I kind of halfway got it over me and
I went to sleep again well when I woke
up in the morning there's no blanket
there's no blanket anywhere near me
didn't exist
I had a lucid dream about covering
myself with a blanket while I was
sleeping on this couch very strange and
in a very primal dreams - like being
chased by wolves and running into bears
and caves and really bizarre very very
vibrant colors and and apparently from
what I've read marijuana does something
to suppress REM sleep and that in taking
time off of it your your REM sleep just
gets jacked through the roof you know
I've heard this many many times I've
never seen a clinical study on it but
it's the type of thing you hear so many
times you have pretty good confidence
that this is true well we all
experienced it all my friends who did it
experience that are in particularly
probably smokes as much as I do maybe
more I'm experienced it deeply I'm glad
you mentioned lucid dreams because this
is a nice segue to I think the greatest
discovery I've made of my life and I
want as all came through a lucid dream
so let me let me set the stage here and
colony collapse disorder is a threat to
worldwide food biosecurity and killing
bees bees around the world are being
decimated say the name of the disorient
colony collapse disorder lapse disorder
now bees are dying off in enormous
quantities Oklahoma lost eighty five
percent of his beehives last year this
2016-2017
the annual loss of bees report
and Marilyn lost 75% Nebraska I think
lost 60% I met a beekeeper in Washington
State who lost 75% of his 35,000 hives
now apis mellifera is the honeybee and
it's factory farmed now and the almond
harvest in California is the biggest
market for beekeepers who send their
bees to the almond orchards one being
can pollinate a thousand flowers in a
day so every flower that bee visits is
an almond so it's one of the most be
dependent crops in the world 35% of your
food is directly dependent upon bee
pollination the other 65% much of that
is indirectly dependent but hey alfalfa
and clover for cows all of our dairy is
dependent upon bee pollination all of
our berries all of our nuts Coffee is
even cannabis and other non dependent
plants benefit from what's called buzz
pollination because the bees then can
could spread the pollen better through
the air it is now thought by many of the
entomologists I've been dealing with
that we could have full colony collapse
across the world within ten years the
cost it will be astronomical to our
society prices where food will raise
poverty will increase you can make the
argument that increased poverty leads to
terrorism because people are poorer
they're desperate and so colony collapse
now is much worse than most people
realize because all the wild bees have
now been infected so 80% of pollination
services come from wild bees and 20%
comes from managed honeybees apis
mellifera is from honey bee from Europe
brought over in the 1700s in 1984 the
varroa mite was introduced in the United
States and the varroa mite has is like a
is a parasite on the backs of bees and
injects viruses in particularly deformed
wing virus the lake Sinai virus and the
black queen Saul virus the deformed wing
virus is the really the most important
one
bees used to go and they only live 30
days but now they used to go Paul
for nine days so they leave the hive and
they pollinate for about nine days they
bring back pollen and that's their
service to the hive and they die off now
the average time for pollination is only
four days they order to fight the mites
they've been using a toxic insecticide
called Emma trows Emma tries fights is
licensed for fighting ticks on cattle at
using cattle strength doses of
amitrano's off-label beekeepers been
drenching their hives with a mattress
twice per year now that might have build
up tolerance and now they're up to nine
times a year they're soaking the highs
in order to kill the mites the mites are
injecting these viruses this is all
hands on deck this is the the per
variable shit's gonna hit the fan on
this this is extremely important and
interestingly it's the number one bridge
issue between liberals and conservatives
so when you're at Thanksgiving dinner or
Christmas or Hanukkah if you want to
avoid talking about Trump and politics
and Hillary or Benghazi or whatever
that's subject you know dispute is talk
about bees everyone's on board on
protecting the bees so I had a waking
dream first 1984 I had two beehives I
planted a mushroom in my garden called
the garden giant and one time this
summer I came out with the water my
mushrooms and it was covered with bees
and the bees moved the wood chips aside
and I could see these white mycelium and
they were sipping on the little droplets
of my sneezing from the my cilia I got
real excited and I kept a journal and
for 40 days from dawn to dusk there's a
continuous convoy bees to my mushroom
bed there's an edible edible mushroom
and I made note of it I published it and
in herre Smith magazine 1988 I put it in
one of my books in 1994 and then I
forgot about it so I got involved with
the US Bioshield bio defense program
directly after 9/11 you can google my
name Stamets and smallpox there's a
vetted press release from the US
government we-we-we they did two
thousand two hundred plus analyses of
our mushroom extracts
and we found extracts that were highly
active against flu viruses against
including bird flu against herpes and
against poxviruses including smallpox so
I have a patent that issued on this it's
a great secondary story because I'd you
know Blackhawk helicopters coming over
my laboratory all this other stuff it's
a fine true conspiracy story so I had
published this research on the antiviral
properties of mushrooms the mycelium and
then I heard about the bees you know I'd
raise bees and then a friend of mine
Louis Schwartzberg we're doing a movie
called fantastic fungi that's in the
making for ten years and Louie came to
me and said Paul I have eight patents on
fungi that can control termites ants
mosquitoes
you can Google right now stamps can take
down Monsanto there's probably a
thousand websites because my patents are
disruptive patents so I can very much
control termites and ants from consuming
your house for about twenty cents and
and I met with all the big companies but
but anyhow so Louie knew about my
research on that I've spoken on this
before and he said Paul the mites are
killing the bees can't you do something
to help the mites and so now okay that's
two stories we have this Bioshield bio
defense story and my anti viral stuff we
have me going the mushrooms in the
garden and a hike in the old-growth
forest a lot and I'm hiking the
old-growth forest and the way I orient
here it's one of the few skills that's
on how I like just getting off trail and
I'm in South Fork of the whole river and
I'm deep in the old-growth forest I come
around a corner and I see a bear strike
that bear came up Pam scratched his tree
a huge paw strike and the tree and I
told my wife I said you know the
Washington State the school system is
dependent upon funding from selling
timber to the lumber lumber companies so
the school system depended upon timber
harvest off of public lands so in the
humans great wisdom they decided that
the Bears
were jeopardizing the educational funds
in Washington State so they hired
hunters to kill all the bears so my
neighbor killed 400 bears that's why we
have a salmon run right now on Skookum
Inlet and Kindle Check Point Washington
there's no bears around because they saw
the Bears that threat the economic
stability this will suspend why the
Bears get the Bears and they scratched
the trees have become an entry room for
a polypore mushroom so I told my wife if
this is true let's come back in two
years and see if this polypore mushroom
is growing there these are wood conks
similar to the one my hat is made from
so we came back two years later and sure
enough this wood conch was growing out
of the tree the tree had died so they
kind of got a right
so when bears scratch trees resin comes
out and bees are attracted to the
propolis to make propolis from the
resins to patch their hives from cracks
prevent invaders coming into a bee hive
these are all seemingly disparate
stories and this is why this wakingdream
put it all together so I have my garden
giant and you know bed the bees are
coming to I have the bio shield bio
defense program where I found these
extracts are highly active against
viruses barren scraps trees introduced
polypore mushrooms and then my friend
Louie Schwartzberg is saying you know
how can you help the bees so and I
highly recommend this to everybody
listening is these lucid dream state at
that state when you're fully asleep and
you just go into the ether of
wakefulness stay there
reside there we have random access
memory before you get your neurological
pathways all set up by habit of what
you're going to do just exists in that
space and then I had synapses activate a
new neurological pathway I had an
epiphany I think I know how to save the
bees fast-forward now I have multiple
patents issuing all over the world we've
done research Washington State
University we've gathered 2.5 million
dollars you can go to WS w WB e SW su
dot edu so the Washington University D U
for education and you'll see the
resource that
have there we are now I have found that
the extracts of Amadou the one my hat is
made from doubles the lifespans of bees
it reduces the deformed wing virus by
more than a thousandfold in ten days I
hit Joe the friggin homerun I'm not an
entomologist I mean I I have two
beehives I'm not even a big beekeeper
but I put these thoughts together that
if these mushroom extracts reduce
viruses that harm humans pigs and birds
what would they do with bees now we all
grew up with Winnie the Pooh
so my US patent issued this past year
and now it's issued in Australia United
States issuing in Europe Eurasia in
Canada I plan to open source it for the
rest of the world but I was waiting on
pins and needles because certainly it
would be something called prior art now
patents are issued for based on several
criteria one no prior art no one's ever
mentioned it secondly contrary to
conventional wisdom so if you invented
the bicycle the wheel then you came out
with a tricycle that's not patentable
that's pretty obvious because it's
logical so you want something there's no
no evidence design in the literature the
public or private or scientific or
popular you wanted the contrary to
conventional and conventional wisdom
which means that you want experts to
teach away for your invention so every
time someone out there and tells me that
that tells I hear that Paul Stamets this
is full of crap nothing he says is true
I have one great response I say thank
you you're helping my patentability
because the more experts that teach away
from my invention the more
unconventional my invention is hence the
more patentable it is the third criteria
is usefulness Benjamin Franklin could
not have invented the iPhone there's no
usefulness with no self cell towers so
these are three criteria after 17 years
it becomes open-source the idea is to
incentivize you know inventors that's
why you have the iPhone the Droid your
computers you know and one person called
me up in a cell phone said how dare you
patent this I go how dare you speak to
me on a cell phone that was enabled by a
patent so you could tell me that I
shouldn't be patenting things I'm just
like
is the contradictions are pretty obvious
so the Pattinson now have issued and
there was no prior art even though we
all grew up with the Winnie the Pooh
we knew that bears went into rotted
trees to find honey and beehives no one
apparently - until me made the
connection that bees are attracted to
the mycelium and rotted logs because of
the immunological benefit now let's go
back in time because it's a very big
picture concept here 12,000 years ago we
invented agriculture what do we do
we started to DeForest when we started
cutting down the trees we began to
dismantle the immunological mycelial
Nets of Nick of nature mycelium needs
wood to decompose you take away the wood
there's mycelium doesn't have a habitat
because the mycelium is produced these
antiviral compounds rotting the wood the
bees were attracted and because of
deforestation now we're stressing the
bees so there's not only the lack of
habitat deforestation there's now
neonicotinoids bear and Sinden Syngenta
that produces new necks as they're known
a toxic insecticide sponsored research
in Europe because they didn't believe
that new and nick annoyed harmed the
bees there be research the researchers
then finally published when they got the
results that was contrary to the
interests of Syngenta and and bear that
in fact new nick de noids harm the
second and third generations now
neonicotinoids are now banned in europe
they are not banned in the United States
so you have drift of these
neonicotinoids on their adjacent fields
so you have loss of wood deforestation
you have new and different noise you
don't glide phosphates over there
especially with GMOs because they
interfere with a microbiome of the bees
and their gut flora so they can't
detoxify them it's called the cytochrome
p450 pathway I think we all have it
breaking down toxins so there's a
confluence of multiple stressors but the
nail in the coffin by far is the
deformed wing virus and we have found
now that the extracts of this one drop
per thousand drops one milliliter and a
leader can reduce the viruses and bees
by more than thousand fold and double
the lifespan so it's a frigging homerun
because it protects food biosecurity
around the world at a time that food
ecosystems are collapsing but think of
the bigger picture here
for millions of years we were forced
people we began deforestation we got
into agriculture we began to dismantle
the immunological networks of nature the
mycelium this resident the fact that
these same mushrooms reduced viruses and
bees pigs birds people speaks to me of a
bigger concept that the mycelium is part
of the immunity of the ecosystem and as
we lose the debris fields that the
mycelium is dependent upon we began to
dismantle the immunological health of
our environment and zoonotic diseases
ceases coming from factory farms whether
they're from pigs or chicken farms and
we have one extraordinary experiment and
this speaks to the the blackhawk
helicopter the story is that I was
working with a bio shield by a defense
program directly after 9/11 they
contacted me because I wrote an article
that was a one-page analysis of all the
research on the antiviral properties of
mushrooms in scientific literature I
wrote this article published in a
peer-reviewed journal bioterrorism
became the front and center of concern
of the US Defense Department a group of
virologists saw my article and they got
funded by Dick Cheney and George Bush
and I have a you know I want to say
thank you ironically to those two
because they front of the bow shield is
called project by a bio defense and they
found it with several billion dollars
and they contacted me because I knew I
had this large library of about 700
strains of mushrooms in our culture
library we have a company of 78 great
employees and we had this large library
so they said we want to test your
library based on this article that
you've written showing there are
antiviral properties in some mushrooms
you have a lot of them this test your
library to see if we have antiviral
properties so great so I started making
extracts of mushrooms the fruit bodies
the mycelium the low elements as fuzzy
stuff that gives rise to mushrooms and I
sent off 100 extracts at a time all
coated with alphanumeric codes so they
didn't know government didn't know about
sending them
so I get the first reports come back and
I'm flipping through them no activity no
activity against poxviruses because by
far the concern with smallpox the
biggest that's we have no immune logical
defense against it after 1974 they
stopped immunizing do you have a
smallpox vaccination on your arm yeah
you're probably one of the last ones
that were getting it so I'm going
through and I come to sample 78 this at
high activity whoa
you know sample 81 high activity whoa I
got really excited I look at my notebook
with the codes were and it was from this
mushroom called a gerakan that grows
exclusively in the old-growth forests of
the Pacific Northwest this mat is the
longest living mushroom in North America
it's a perennial polypore it looks like
a giant beehive by coincidence you know
up on a tree so you can get a picture
that Jamie and so a gerakan AGA RI kon
and so i got real excited and i so i I
was given a contact person could he had
one point of contact with you Justice
Department a physician I called him up
saying these these research results were
wonderful he goes what research results
I go Federal Express just delivered me
this whole dossier on the first hundred
samples Wow and and he goes you're not
supposed to get those I am I said well
I'll photocopy and send him to you you
know and so he didn't think that was too
funny
but that's the US government sometimes
it's not very well organized the left
hand doesn't talked on the right hand so
we got these research results it's crazy
there looks like a stick up a dude's but
what this one is this one is
particularly unusual because if it was
attached to an upper branch it fell
through the air oh wow hit the other
branch and teeter-totter
and then it regrew its mycelium and
connected back into the mother my
selling beside the tree and then it grew
two legs so this is like this was first
described by the ice karate since 65 ad
as elix cerium ad long in vitam the
elixir of long life so this has been
used in Greek pharmacopoeia for for for
thousands of years so please get back to
your store sorry for the interruption No
so anyhow
I am up in Canada and one of my managers
calls me up says Paul there's a
helicopter room whoever the laboratory
is I know no big deal and helicopters
come and go no it's really close I said
how close he goes listen to me troop
whoa that's really close I go what are
the numbers in the back of the
helicopter he goes there are no numbers
there's a Blackhawk helicopter I want oh
my gosh now just because this is very
new in the program when because when you
have an antidote to a weapon then it can
be weaponized by terrorists so they
didn't who you know not everybody in the
government knew who I was even though I
was working with a project bio defense
you know I was still sort of unknown
entity and I filed a patent application
on this and so I told my manager okay
shut down the business give everybody
cultures of this mushroom which was a
gerakan I don't want to know who has
them shut down the business everyone
spread so we decentralized assaulted our
target but hold on so let me stop you
right there so you're in Canada Jorma
Canada you'll Abbas we're in the United
States okay in Washington State and the
helicopters are flying over your lab
what happens then well they were trying
to spook they were spooking us and we
sued on purpose they were doing the
purpose they were hovering to let you
know they're there I don't know what
they were doing I mean there are a
treetop level right over the friggin
laboratory right so I had everyone go to
our car I asked everyone to go in the
car shut down the business immediately
and decentralize us as a target so later
on when I came back I called that my
people in the Defense Department saying
what the right the hell's going on here
I think oh geez you know sometimes the
left hand doesn't talk to the right
we're sorry
so eventually so how did they find out
they just from your patent filing well
the patent I filed the patent and it
disappeared most patent applications
when you filed them show up on the US
patent homepage within a year or two I
filed his patent and four or five years
later he still had not been published so
I get a hold of my patent attorney who
gets a hold of Patent Office and the US
Department of Defense considered to be
an act natural security so they
quarantined my patent took it out of the
Patent Office
and they so it could not be seen by
potential terrorists because then it
could have an antidote smallpox so I had
to do the inter government a
governmental agency traced to recall the
patent from DoD that meetings they let
out to be released because it was a
natural product and so the patent then
was put back into the patent application
queue and it was approved in 2013 I
found it in 2004 so we have now done
work at the University of Mississippi
School of Pharmacy we have isolated two
novel anti smallpox molecules we also
have done work at the tuberculosis
Research Institute with dr. Scott
franzblau and University of Illinois in
Chicago we've identified a new
anti-tuberculosis molecule a gerakan and
die square at his time and Greek culture
was used for treating consumption later
thought to be known as tuberculosis we
have found that extracts of this
mushroom are duly active against
bacteria and viruses most people who die
from viral pneumonia actually died from
bacterial pneumonia they get a viral
infection they owed their immune system
over amps and it's a response to get
flood and lungs get flooded with liquid
bacteria set up and bacterial pneumonia
usually kills people who actually get a
flu virus they die from bacterial
pneumonia so to find a natural products
as dually active against viruses the
bacteria is medically significant so
it's a good argument for natural
products because you have a consortium
of protective agents that are living in
this soup of this extract that can help
help protect you so this is now led on
to are discovering molecules active
against HPV the human papilloma virus
70% or more of women have HPV this is
very controversial vaccine apparently
it's very dangerous well I'm not anti
evacuee oxidation but I'm not either but
I'm curious why they don't recommend the
vaccine after the age of 24 I can't wrap
my mind around from sexually active kids
well your secondly octave out for the
age of 24 so why when tight but they're
sexually active before then but if you
were didn't have the infection before 24
and you're still active at the
24:00 why wouldn't they recommend the
vaccinations half of the age of 24 maybe
there's amend it post 24 is that we use
24 also post 24 they don't recommend it
because they think maybe you already
have it I don't know the answer to that
that's bizarre I've never been able to
get someone to explain to me what
mushrooms can suppress the expression of
this is that we're saying the
ingredients within the mushrooms we have
found five molecules authenticated by
NIH virology as being potently active
against HPV which mushrooms all the poly
pores that I have been talking about
reishi gerakan Amadou are likely we
don't I can't say de facto all of them
to have varying amounts of these
constituents so these mushroom extracts
are a huge consortium of of antiviral
antibacterial compounds now as I
mentioned this may be five million
species of fungi there is about 150,000
species of mushrooms we've identified
identified around 14,000 so think of
them it just from experience all
evidence over thousands of years of
human experimentation it'd be like you
went into a library and there's 14,000
books in your library 14,000 species our
ancestors started selecting each of
these species and testing them we've
narrowed the field down to about 200
species of which 50 species are
superstars that have no adverse effects
to human ingestion that have been used
for a very long period of time and
within that set of 50 species we're
finding these mushrooms which have
tremendous potential health benefit so
this is why I'm so excited in the field
of my ecology is we have translational
science we have applied my ecology and I
think based on what we've discovered we
can make the argument that we should
save the old-growth forests as a matter
of national defense our fungal gene
genomes are essential for our future and
present survival the more we eliminate
these landscapes of biodiversity the
more we losing but
seneschal agents that can fight disease
and so this is something that I think we
can build a bridge between conservatives
and liberals because Osama bin Laden and
have access to an old-growth forest you
know we did and we do and I think this
is really just indicative of many other
things that we can discover if we pay
attention to the vast genomic resources
we have in the biodiversity of the
ecosystems that are that are still
intact
now do you recommend for personal
consumption any particular mushrooms any
particular supplements I in terms of
recommend recommendations for gourmet
mushrooms I can make those in terms of
recommendations for medicinal mushrooms
I cannot make a recommendation so I'm
legally tied by the FDA I cannot make
recommendations can you recommend a
website that perhaps would recommend
well I I do recommend eating gourmet
mushrooms for just consumed shiitake
lion's mane maitake and reishi and chaga
and these all have medical benefits as
well he's all I don't know the
difference between a gourmet and
medicinal or medicinal mushroom and it
just mushrooms yeah the much all gourmet
mushrooms are medicinal mushrooms really
social taki mushrooms are medicinal
shiitake mushrooms are very very
medicinal the big the big stars right
now by far are reishi chaga and lion's
mane what about Portobello they taste
too good they can't be that good for you
portobellos have a problem I knew it all
much all mushrooms should be cooked and
portobellos in particular should be
cooked at high temperatures why there is
a unfortunate group of compound called
Garrett teens Garrett teens are
hydrazines that are heat unstable so the
good news is you should cook them and if
you cook them well then there's
mushrooms or another problem if you
don't cook them well then these
hydrazines are potentially problematic
now nature is a numbers game so there
are beneficial compounds that
in some balance may outweigh the
negative effects of the hydrazines the
Agera teens in these mushrooms but that
jury is still out so what what are the
negative benefit or the negative effects
of this this is an explosive area of
conversation and puts my life in danger
so I reserve the right not to answer a
question whoa I didn't expect that it
puts your life in danger talking about
portobello mushrooms he's looking at me
silently I will respectfully move on
thank you um so anybody who's interested
just google that get back to me you know
next I'm gonna have a guy who was the
same height as Paul and he's gonna have
a mask on and we're gonna have sort of
electric box that distorts the voice no
but the good news is tell you the story
yeah there's lots of mushrooms that have
a tremendous benefit and and there are
compounds inside of portobello mushrooms
that are very beneficial and in fact
there is a positive study with some
breast cancer patients breast cancer
study showing that that button mushrooms
can confer benefits so there is that
yeah we were funded by NIH with a 2.2
million dollars for breast cancer
clinical study on turkey tail mushrooms
and turkey tail mushrooms are fantastic
as adjuncts to conventional therapy this
clinical study that was conducted funded
by NIH and in the University of
Minnesota Medical School in mr. McCall
College showed a dose-response curve
specifically and supporting the immune
system by taking turkey tail mushrooms
and the more you took the more benefit
there was I have a TEDMED talk that's
very popular in front of 800 physicians
where my mother who was challenged with
advanced stage 4 breast cancer who is
now 90 almost 93 years of age she had
advanced stage 4 breast cancer when she
was 84 years of age given less than a
few months to live and she had
metastasized tumors all over her body
or breast was erupting with a
very very bad carcinoma and she is alive
well and fully recovered today she did
she had a chemotherapy using Herceptin
and a little of short-time attacks all
she had a very bad reaction attacks all
but there's a scientific articles now
been published saying that showing that
turkey tail mushroom constituents help
conventional therapies like chemotherapy
Herceptin and making it Herceptin work
better so there's a nice blending of
Integrative Medicine with using natural
products with conventional medicine I
will never be saying that you should not
consult a physician I would never say
that you should not use conventional
medicine you should yes the state of the
art of science is right there but the
state of the arts of science is that we
can up regulate immunity with these
mushrooms and that's your front line of
defense and then the other conventional
therapies that are being practiced now
combined very very nicely according to
many physicians and reports showing that
the combination of turkey tail mushrooms
in combination with conventional therapy
can have a significant in difference in
improving your illogical defense now I
absolutely agree with you that
conventional treatments are
state-of-the-art and this is
state-of-the-art science when you're
talking about dealing with cancer you
should deal with oncologists that are at
the cutting edge but they're not
state-of-the-art when it comes to the
preventing of these things and that
that's a giant issue that a lot of
people have when it comes to nutrition
lifestyle mitigating stress all the
various factors that contribute to a
bunch of different health ailments do
you think that mushrooms could also play
a factor in that as well
absolutely absolutely there's a great
epidemiological study that came out of
Japan and doctor Ichikawa was a edema
ologists that worked for the National
Cancer Center in Tokyo and they notice
and surveying people in Japan in the
1960s early 1970s there was a dearth a
drop and the overall cancer rate and
this one population and the
perfec sure in Japan so he was sent
there by the National Cancer Center of
Tokyo by the government to say what are
these people doing in this one cluster
of villages where they have
statistically significant less cancer
rates we're talking about 30 percent
less than the national average and an
after exhaustive study he found that
they were eating enoki mushrooms a lot
of them because he enoki mushrooms are
really thin ones that really tall stems
you buy them in the store well the far
the big farming centers for enoki
mushrooms there and then the blemished
ones is called reverted there's no we
don't you know sell to the public the
ones that have little spots on them or
deformed but they are given to the
workers and so they're workers and then
their families eat a higher per capita
consumption of enoki mushrooms than the
other residents of Japan so they found
that specifically the consumption of
enoki mushrooms resulted in a reduction
of cancer across the board of all
cancers statistically significant I
think over 220,000 people this
epidemiological survey I've written
about 10 articles for the Huffington
Post and you can google Stamets
Huffington Post and enoki mushrooms and
see all the citations on the enoki
mushrooms on lion's mane on the gerakan
all these mushrooms I'm talking about
they're all peer-reviewed passed
physicians they're all very short
articles but they summarize a lot of the
research that I'm talking about that's
amazing what what do you know about the
cordyceps mushroom I know a fair amount
about cordyceps
yeah I'm fascinated from two reasons one
because of a supplement that I take that
my company makes called shroom tech
sport sorry for the name my apologies in
advance but it's based on athletic
performance about the shrimp tech is
based on the cordyceps and b12 and a
bunch of different adaptogens and the
idea being that when you take that it
benefits athletic performance benefits
endurance and oxygen utilization and
apparently they discovered this from
what it's a weird one because they grow
it on on a caterpillar do you know about
all that yeah
cordyceps is now it's been split into
several different genre yeah
so I was gonna bring up another one is
the one that explodes on ants yeah
there's there's quarter SEPs census now
known as a Pheo
quarter census quarter steps has about
500 species in it it's been a very
complicated taxonomy because when
researchers would go in the Himalayas
and they find these caterpillars where
the cordyceps mushrooms coming out of it
very good scientists and they did this
what I would do they would take it in a
laboratory they'd break it open and take
a piece of tissue from the inside that's
called cloning so you just capture their
genetic material you grow out the
culture very confusing because there is
five different fungi they're called
Animorphs cordyceps is a dimorphic
fungus what that means that's two forms
it's got a mold state and it's got a
mushroom state the mushroom snake comes
up like a little Club looks like your
finger we go you know orange the orange
little finger coming up out of the
ground so you can find that jam and the
yeah so they say expired caterpillar I
can't actually see the species there but
it look like they're beetles so there's
a number of course of species so when
there was a lot of scientific dispute on
what the true Animorph now as two sides
of the same coin
you see the cordyceps and then you clone
it and you get this mold growing and
then people will grow up the mold well
now we know there are several species of
molds that are growing inside the
caterpillar so the true cat except a
quarter step census is now identified as
hirsute Ella consensus that's the true
one basilio my C's and meta resume and
all these other ones are not considered
to be the true organism they're chasing
the other quarter SEPs mold inside of
the mushroom whoa I'm gonna go over many
many many many a polyculture polycomb as
a poly called for several different
animal pathogenic fungi these are front
of the kill insects so I mean this is
very it's very disruptive because all
the FDA in the labeling how
what do you do and who's right and who's
wrong and how do you get the labeling to
conform with the current taxonomy based
on DNA research the the good news is
based on the best of my knowledge the
several of these companies that are
selling these quarter steps they
Animorphs even though they may not be
the true core substances those also
confer benefits so you can argue in a
sense about different species the
problem with this is there's no less
than a thousand peer-reviewed articles
on cordyceps and Ensis and no one or
hardly anyone no one knows what species
they were actually growing why is it we
don't know which which of these animals
that were actually growing there was
this recent information that all very
recent all in the past four or five
years and especially in the past two
years so Wow it's um taxonomy is in flux
because of DNA PCR amplification in the
region of DNA that they've chosen they
amplify there are idiosyncratic to the
species now that story has changed whole
genome sequencing is really the only way
to go about this with a sequence the
entire genome and so there's a lot of
elasticity or plasticity and and the and
the expression of DNA now going back
what we've been talking about this whole
interview epigenesis epigenesis is the
an environment emulation of influence on
the genomic expression of the individual
the species yourself and so you up
regulate or turn on genes that are
otherwise quote-unquote asleep and so
what we're seeing now is that epigenetic
influences can cause different DNA
expressions and so what was considered
to be conformity of a species and DNA
types before like 99% and that was
thought that oh these are the same
species now we know that's highly
inaccurate so what was accurate a few
years ago was considered to be highly
inaccurate today the science is changing
very very rapidly and the regulatory
environment cannot catch up so it
doesn't really matter except for the
following and this is I do make a
recommendation
here make sure your mushrooms or
whatever procs you're consuming are
certified organic and please don't buy
them from China anyone who's been to
China I've been to China several times
the amount of mass of air pollution
there is horrific and the Chain of
Custody as we call it where these people
are getting their mushrooms today it
mixed oftentimes distributors mixed
suppliers and it's a form of quote
unquote Russian Roulette we've done
analyses on Chinese sourced mushrooms
and they've had up to 2,200 parts per
million of lead where two or three
capsules is toxic so why would you take
a medicinal mushroom this contaminate
with heavy metals and pesticides if
you're trying to improve your immune
system at the same time you're
sabotaging your own immune system so
getting mushrooms from clean
environments is critically important
unfortunately because the USDA Organic
Program they can borrow from their
organic programs of China and still say
there are certified organic so you
really need to buy US grown certified
organic mushrooms that have a clear
chain of custody and hopefully one that
is from a reputable supplier or
scientist and not somebody who's just
trying to make money there's a lot of
opportunistic companies right now we're
just trying to exploit and ride the
bandwagon of the popularity of medicinal
mushrooms without really having done
their homework or without fully
informing the public that there are
mushrooms are actually coming from China
when they are not what is the strain of
cordyceps mushroom that erupts that
infects ants kills them sprouts out of
them then explodes and infects the ants
near them and other ants will drag that
ant knowing that it's infected deep deep
away into the forest well it away from
the colony just a quarter steps lordy I
up on the screen there hold on yeah of
course employ di you you know you
unilateralis is another one a lot of
these zombie movies you've been saying
they've been based on cordyceps and Knox
I was actually I was a character in
Hannibal Lecter you were yeah in this
series I think it's number five and and
this L I think Alvin Stannis was this
anesthesiologist there was last name
yeah use my last name and they just call
you Paul well they do on Star Trek I'm a
character yeah I know yeah they actually
call me Paul
Stan was on Star Trek but Hannibal
Lector that series I always people write
me said oh my gosh you're this evil
doctor who overdoses his patients with
with drugs and then puts them in the
backyard and then inoculate them with
mushrooms just like cordyceps you know
so you have mushrooms going in the
backyard and some of the Star Trek
people called me up in August of 2016
I'm talking to them they CBS you know
settled up they have to talk to you
that's all my TED talk and and they said
Paul were the writers of the Star Trek
Discovery Series we're kind of stuck you
know we want to talk to you we saw your
TED talk we're really interested in I go
wait a second are you the one who put me
in the Hubble Lecter it goes yeah I go
let's get it right this time you know so
I said okay I said foolishly before
maybe to my benefit foolishly I said
turn on your tape recorder you know give
me the general idea and let me run with
it and they said ok go for it there's
six of them I guess in the conference
call foolishly I said I'm a Star Trek
fan which is not foolish but I want no
money for these ideas I give you all my
intellectual property
I do want science fiction to predict
science fact the great thing about Star
Trek is the flip phone and the iPad I
mean those came out in Star Trek and
then it became reality I said so you
have a unique opportunity here of
forming our future let's collaborate to
create a future that's better for our
future generations by inspiring students
and young people to get excited about
the science so they can help populate
the universities to create from the
inventions that can help save this
planet that's in jeopardy and so I ran
with a Star Trek theme and we just saw
the last episode last night and Astro
mycologist Paul Stamets is a using the
mycelium spore drive it has become I
couldn't believe it we're watching this
thing and the Star Trek the main theme
of Star Trek is based on mycelium and
the concepts that I gave them they've
elaborated this I mean six ways to
Sunday so they've really taken it this
is as some sort of a propulsion system
it's a partisan system because in my TED
talk and I've been talking about a long
time about networks we have the mycelial
Network we have the computer internet we
have the neurological network and our
brains in the organization of a dark
matter conforms to string theory so
these are three are katha the same
archetype the same dimensional
structures stacked on top of each other
and nature builds upon his prior
successes so networks reward themselves
by surviving and it was from
catastrophic so I said and I'm still
bound by confidentiality and there's an
incredibly strict confidentiality
agreement I can only state which has
been publicly displayed but the mycelium
sport allows through the internet of
nature you might say to be able to go
into hyperspace immediately by tapping
into the mycelial archetype and so Astro
mycologist amis now is plugging himself
into the mycelial network of the
universe and they can jump rather than
using their standard hyperdrives which
will you see them streaming across four
hours from one part of the university of
the other they can show up immediately
and then and then disappear is this
something that you think that actually
be real one day I okay you know what
pushing the envelope baby does it
pushing the envelope on this one but if
you look at the multiverse and I've had
a I've had one or two in particular
multiverse experiences where time and
reality has changed in a way that I
cannot explain it so what do you mean
it's so incredibly profound that I still
cannot wrap my mind around it and these
are psilocybin experience psilocybin
experience so I think the psilocybin
experience might be a one rule portal
and now I'm gonna sound like Terence
Mckenna
a vendor ring in to the multiverse the
idea that time can be bent that there
are multiple universes occurring
simultaneously in different realities
and I've had one experience in
particular that is just unfathomable to
me I don't know how to explain it is a
shot okay I'll give it a shot and you've
already blown my mind 50 times today
is it a very deeply personal experience
to me but um I was uh I was going to the
Evergreen State College I had the Drug
Enforcement Administration license my
brother John went to Yale University he
got a graduate scholarship in
neurophysiology at the University of
Washington he came out to Washington
State in Seattle I was living in Olympia
Washington
I had a cabin up in the mountains near
Darrington Washington then a summer time
for three years I sat chokers I was a
logger I really believe in the school of
hard knocks and the blending of academia
with with blue-collar hard work I loved
chopping wood I loved running a chainsaw
I love hard labor I think it gives my
mind some respite to be able to think so
I'm in this highly academic environment
my brother John is he died unfortunately
two years ago he sue see he got me
involved in mushrooms so I'm gonna segue
and set the stage here but I needed
another two minutes to set the stage
here so I'm growing up in a small town
in Ohio called Columbiana my brother
John goes that his going to Yale he
comes back one one day and he gives me a
book that he's using for his class but
he's on break and he says I never really
X fasted that John went to Mexico
Colombia came back with a great stories
of heating suicide mushrooms and was my
older brother I just idolized him
and his book called altered states of
consciousness and so I said John can I
borrow your book he said sure and I said
but Paul you get back you know from my
break is over I'm going back to college
it's as part of our textbook so I bought
his book altered states of consciousness
I'm just fascinated reading it you know
about all these different ways of
expanding your consciousness I'm
fourteen years of age and so my best
friend Ryan Schneider says Paul can I
borrow your book we're hanging together
all the time anyway I need it back so he
bought was my book and he doesn't return
it a day you know several days passed a
week pass you know two weeks passed my
brother's coming back on break I said I
needed that book ball back Paul and I go
to Ryan I go Ryan I need my book I need
my book and Ryan kept avoiding the
answering the subject until finally give
me my book and Ryan goes I can't give it
to you Paul I said why
this is my dad burned it I see your dad
burned my brothers book I go WTF I
didn't use this phrase back then I said
oh my god
and I have a shout out to Ryan Snyder's
father that because of that event it
stimulated my interest in altered states
of consciousness even more so that so
John goes to Yale and goes to the
University of Washington I have this DEA
permit I'm at the Evergreen State
College John calls me up I says Paul I
think I found some suicide mushrooms
Johnson you're really smart you've been
collecting salafi cubensis and Colombia
and Mexico but you know they're much
more complicated up here and then I said
let me ask you a few questions
I said okay John you take a spore print
he goes yes I go as a spores purple
Brown he goes yes they are purple Brown
I go good okay
no John does it have a separable
gelatinous pellicle and he goes what's
that and I go well
break the cap these are growing on wood
chips great break the cap and and
separate the cap very slowly do you see
a little skin that's translucent he
breaks it he goes yeah you see that skin
the John the growing in wood chips and
he goes yes I go but a turning bluish he
goes yes they're staining really bright
blue oh wow
I said John how many did you find he
goes you would not believe it there's a
huge amount I said wait I say but he the
Paul they're a very sensitive place you
better come up here right away so I
jumped in my car drove up from Olympia
to Seattle about 6070 miles I get to his
house and I and John's errand and I go
well where are we gonna go so well we
need some grocery bags you know and
let's get on our bikes and let's go down
there I go why all the secrecy and and
the problem is is well you'll see and it
was the end of boat Street and right at
the University of Washington a right off
of University Avenue there's boat Street
and we get there and right across the
street is a police substation
so we're there and it was an eruption of
this mushroom that had to be ten
thousand thirty thousand mushrooms I
don't know it was about 50 feet by 30
feet whether they all been multiple wood
chips there was an eruption that picked
up
you know trash and you know debris that
picked up six inches with solid
mushrooms or mushrooms everywhere I've
to this day never seen so many mushrooms
in one concentrated area so we waited
till the police cars went away and we're
kind of idling there and then the police
cars will go away and for the substation
we start making much for picking my
friend and we felt the groceries back
back where to and and then the other
students are walking by what are you
doing oh nothing you know and then we
eventually got yeah there's plenty for
everybody
so it was like pretty good everyone all
hang and I was a little group like at
the bus stop right we're not really
waiting for the bus right we're waiting
for the police cars to go away right and
then we picked all these mushrooms so we
got about eight or ten grocery bags full
of these mushrooms on it turn out to be
a new species called philosophy spoon
see I'm named after a new species new
species new as in hadn't been discovered
by describe pictures of scientific
literature before so you picked a
mushroom that no one knew existed well
we've been haven't been described
scientifically we had known about it for
about three years but this is the
largest eruption and from that
collection became part of what of the
type collection that anchored the
species taxonomically so I think some of
the specimens still exist in her barrier
around the world because it's the
reference standard so we go back to the
house and it's like we got to dry them
so we lay out newspapers and the whole
the whole newspapers were just covered
with mushrooms and and so that night and
we there's about the four guys from Yale
all in neurophysiology all scientists
and on scientists and Trackman it says
eat them and so I mean this is not very
potent they're 1/10 the potency of
cubensis so we made smoothies oh my gosh
talk about the gag reflex our we had
make these smoothies we had eat 50 of
them in order to have a dose equivalent
equipment Westlaw speak events this
would be so I knew that so we made it
incredibly distasteful milkshakes and
and we chucked them here we drank them
and and then amazing experience I bonded
with my brother it was beautiful and
then you're peaking at the experience
you look around
like tens of thousands these Muslims
like oh my gosh all for science and so I
go to bed and and I'm laying about it
and you know full-blown experience and
you know can barely sleep because all
the colors are keeping me awake and my
mind is racing and then I have a lucid
dream and I'm dreaming and I wake up and
I go downstairs I go I had this crazy
dream I said what's your dream and I
said I saw thousands of cattle dead
baking in the Sun I said I think there's
gonna be a nuclear war well what could
kill all these cattle you know there's a
time the Reagan administration and and
and all that and you know the the the
attention was really high between the
Soviet Union the United States and they
said then they were joking with me
saying oh well okay you know what it's
gonna happen I go I know I was in
Olympia and I needed to rush up to
Darington to stay in my cabin because my
books were up there my manuscript was up
there I need to save save my research so
they've laughed and they laughed and
said well when's the world will end Paul
and I go well it's not this weekend I
was like in two days it's next weekend
so they wrote on the calendar December
1st I put it in my book on [ __ ] 1975
the end of the world
they wrote Paul predicts the end of the
world so we forgot about it
massive rains the next week huge amounts
of snowfall and then on Wednesday
Thursday temperature inversion and it
flipped to 75 to 85 degrees all the snow
started to melt all the rivers were
flooding and my little cabin was right
next to this river that would swell from
that day didn't of a morning tonight it
would go up six feet just from the snow
melting because very close to this
volcano and big glaciers I said oh my
gosh I'm gonna lose my managed kept all
my research I need to get up there I
need to get up there and so I'm watching
the news on news and the roads are being
closed so how to go through a Rockport
Washington the back way in order to get
back to my cabin I get to my cabin and
the banquette eroded about ten feet I
was only about 10 12 feet away from the
from the river now my cabin was on the
verge of falling into a pike
my manuscript I got him all my books you
know I rescued all the material I had
but I couldn't get out of there because
the roads have been closed and so I had
a right wait two days two days and the
roads then opened up and I drove out out
of the valley into Snohomish Valley and
I went around the bend and there the Sun
it was a brilliant sunny day a warm day
and they are floating in the fields for
hundreds and hundreds of dead cattle how
do you explain that I entered I think
into the multiverse no as a scientist
you realize when you say something like
that you open yourself up to ridicule do
you feel hesitant to communicate these
into degree yes but you know I'm 62
years of age and you know at one point
you don't care I just don't care you
know this is true this happened to me
and I can push the envelope on these
ideas because the credibility of my
research is well-established I can save
the bees do you care whether I have
taken sulfide mushrooms if I can save
your farm your family your country or
the world billions of dollars in protect
biosecurity I care more I care more
that's right so I'm telling you things
I'm not making these up and make more I
don't have to I just but just because
you can't explain it does not mean it's
not true right and I think that we need
to accept the fact that the reality is
not limited to the perception that we
have traditionally used that's a
beautiful way to describe it
let's end with that that's perfect thank
you brother
Paul thank you so much I'm so glad you
came here and thank you to all the
people that recommended you and and turn
me on to your work and could we do this
again
I'd love to please all right and if
people want to research more of your
stuff fungi calm and what was the other
website and host offense comm host
defense calm and there's a ton of other
information TED talk and I have a
youtube.com slash Paul Stamets site and
Louie Schwartzberg shout out we have a
fantastic fungi calm check it out Louie
now are coming out with a movie that
describes much of the stuff thank you so
much all right
thank you brother
[Music]
[Applause]